[Music]
[Music]
hey river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and I'm very
excited because I'm coming to you live
right now it's our last live of the
season and I've got two very special
guests joining me right now
Vanessa Morgan who plays Tony and Skeet
Ulrich who plays FP Jones hi guys and
now we toss them
thank you guys so much for stopping by
and thank you to the fans who are
waiting for us to go live we saw all of
your show knee and phallus shoutouts so
thank you so much if you had any
questions for Vanessa or Skeets
send them in right now because we need
to talk about the fact that there are
only two episodes of Riverdale left did
it feel like the season flew by or
crawled by which part the making or the
viewing the making and then the viewing
the making seem to take a while yeah I
would say crawl okay yeah definitely
crawled yeah but I hate it seems to be
flying by that's what it seems to be
fine but it's crazy now the seasons
already aired it's like oh it aired pre
guys yeah I know I'm so I'm shocked
there's only two yeah I'm excited
because these are really really insane
tonight's episode
I don't think fans are ready for it I
really don't I don't even think that the
definitely aren't ready for it now we
have the promo let's watch it together
and then let's react to the craziness
that we see so let's take a look what
good is an active shooter on the streets
of Riverdale some of the serpents are
edgy with the gun
Riverdale burning to the ground you were
in on this the Ghoulies outnumber us 100
to 1 yeah when I first watched this
promo cuz at this point I've seen it
like a million times little Tony all
tied up I know what can you tease about
that Vanessa what can I choose about it
I mean obviously somebody kidnapped me
mm-hmm I guess we're gonna find out
you're not you're doing that just not
there you know I'm not doing it for fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
but ya know I guess you'll see what
happens tonight but it's definitely a
very scary experience for Tony
definitely ski there are a lot of things
going on for the serpent's as the
reigning serpent king in tonight's
episode what can you tease what what's
going on I find that there is nothing
about this show I continue I mean
obviously we know trouble is brewing
between different factions in the town
and it's it's at a boil now and that
it's about to erupt
so there's some crazy things that go
down well FP warned Jughead many
episodes ago just because you drove
penny Peabody out of town doesn't mean
she's gone for good
she's coming back why do you feel like
she is such a formidable formidable
opponent for the serpens
because it's Britt she is so good I you
know it's clear she has she has a lot of
insider knowledge and for the serpens
against the serpens and she knows how to
maneuver and she's got more than
then you can imagine backing her up so
what'd you think well I agree yeah yeah
when it comes to Brit like she is so
scary and she obviously you know Chuck
had cut off her serpent tattoo and I was
a part of that you were suppose I do it
really scared of you yeah yeah I was to
do it too so I have a target on my back
dun dun dun when you read this script
that's airing tonight what was your
reaction because watching it I was like
I can't even imagine just having to read
this on the page yeah it's I mean it's
everything you see but you know there
was there's probably a bit more to it
than what you see as well that didn't
make it because we tend to shoot more
than we can air but there was a lot of a
lot of tense moments and reading it is
always exciting I think we all get them
and are just so eager to see what's
going on and who's going where and you
know a lot of times you read scripts and
you're so focused on what you're doing
in it but these you just tend to get
lost and oh my god what's going on here
what's going on there and they're
intense well I love that you had
mentioned that because you guys I don't
think fans really realized that you guys
do film so much content and there's only
so much you can pack into 42 minutes and
so some things do inevitably get cut
some of the fans were so bummed that the
Shoni singing scene was cut from the
musical episode but Roberto still
released it he released it yeah I love
you Roberto for that and people were so
so pumped about the performance I was
really happy about that
mm-hmm there was another scene that got
cut from that episode the Dodge County
moment oh yeah it was actually a kiss I
kissed and I gave it brought her some
flowers for her performance but didn't
make it okay
and now I hear all the Shoni fans
probably crying
[Applause]
while we're talking about showing you
right now there is another episode of
Sweetwater secrets that just went live
this morning and in it a fan had said
wait is it Choni or Shoni and i had
talked with madeline patch and we had
established since it's cheryl and not
charile that it is Nonie Shoni so I want
to get it from the other half of show
knee its Joanie okay great yeah we got
it locked in show knee that's the best
ship name awesome
speaking of ships people also love
myself included phallus as an FP and
Alice and ski I'm curious to know what
it has been like for you to be part of
this ship that has become so popular
with the fans well first of all she's an
amazing woman an incredibly talented
full vibrant person and so it makes it
really easy to to play that you know
that attraction and that side of the
relationship it's it's amazing to watch
it grow it's you know it's I mean it was
something we sort of mused on when I was
a guest star in the first season like
one of the first table reads you know
she started throwing it out there I
think we had this thing and then it just
started developing and and Roberto god
bless him jumped right on board and has
loved it the whole way and and supported
it and written to it and it's it's
become quite the thing the scene in Wow
I've seen so many now that I can't
nineteen yes when when she admitted that
you guys did have a child together and
matron was amazing and she was sobbing
it broke my heart what was it like for
you being in that scene with her it's
tough I mean it's you know it's tough
when you know you have to perform at
that height it's you know we also had
come back to that scene we were two
episodes ahead when we shot that scene
we were shooting 21 when we had to go
back and shoot that so she had sort of
lost the the train of emotion that was
going on while she was shooting it so
you know her getting back to it and you
know there were points where she would
get on she'd fall to the floor like in
the middle of shooting that scene and I
pick her up and try and get that emotion
on camera for her and so she it was it's
tough too tough to be a part of it's
tough to watch you know it's kind of one
of those things when even when your dear
friends are like sobbing their hearts
out and like do you you know you want to
support them but then you're also
playing something so it's it's not easy
it's not easy and you know like most of
shooting you get very little time yeah
you know so you're just trying to get
the best you can in a short amount of
time and I mean fortunately she's that
brilliant well it's nice when you have
to have an on-screen connection to had
that off-screen connection as well and
obviously we know Vanessa you are BFFs
with madellaine yes and she told me the
most amazing story that when you guys
had your first kiss in the sisters of
quiet mercy that there was a little bit
of a snot situation there was not a
major snot situation so she's very lucky
that we're best friends and they didn't
even bother me because I was like why
I'm salty and she's like there's a lot
of snobbery and were you did the kiss a
lot it was fine like we're so
comfortable with each other that I was
like it didn't even matter it's like you
know it's like your sister it's like
well that's weird
book your nose like this I would get it
with my own hands ya know what I mean so
we've had so many great guest stars on
Riverdale I need to know though when is
your puppy gonna be on Riverdale it
needs to happen Yoshi
yes well actually they're getting Yoshi
I don't know if you heard about this but
they're getting Yoshi a cast chair for
next season because your she's like a
chair every single day when I'm when I'm
on set he sits on the chair or anyone
elses by the way and he is the like
self-proclaimed emotional support dog on
set okay and he gives a lot of emotional
support to every single person including
Skeet himself I play him in chicken okay
yeah he gets paid in the little Turkey
oh he eaten Wow he's eating he's eating
very well no she loves tacos follow him
on Instagram but he has
like I can't complain my cat likes gummi
bears
but I just think that Yoshi needs a
little serpent jacket he does
that's something I'm I think wardrobe is
gonna give him a patch I just need to
find like cute little like doggy leather
jacket you know as two of my favorite
serpents right now I've got to know when
you guys put on that jacket does it help
you get into character more do you feel
like a kick-butt character represent
absolutely mine's really heavy I don't
know about yours mine's heavier than any
leather jacket I've ever held and
something about the weight of that it's
like armor yeah it definitely makes you
feel badass I do feel really bad after
that do you think that the serpents
could ever start slow they're an outward
could they expand could they expand
their ranks at all
that's um well yeah I mean I know a lot
of fans out there who'd want to be a
serpent yeah yeah it's it's pretty
amazing how rabid people are about the
serpents and I think to some extent it's
because we speak to the you know the
blue-collar hard-working mentality of
most people and but I think it could
expand out I think it's a little tough
right now considering there's like going
on but yeah that would that would be
really interesting to see I love and I
think we see it in the promo or in a
photo that Roberto tweeted but we see
that the serpents have a really cool
little like all gesture they're little
things yeah is that it was that come
from you it did I mean I had you know I
felt like every gang has a sign but I
researched for a while because I've done
things where I had gang tats on and had
been told you know do not wear that
anywhere or you could be dead so you
know gangs are very serious about their
signs so I looked and looked and looked
for something that had you know that I
wasn't repeating something that could
get us in danger
in trouble so it took a while but yeah
it seemed to catch on and we weren't
sure when you know I did it I think the
first time I did it was in when jugheads
playing video games at the white worm
and you know I find him not in school
and we weren't sure whether it was gonna
make the cut there were so many
opportunities to put it in other places
and and once we knew it was kind of
becoming a thing we started putting it
in where it fit yeah
and in France they were all about it
like it's crazy in Paris like I had
people come up to me and go like you
know well we are running out of time
unfortunately but so and also there's
just so much that happens yeah give fans
out there your best advice for what they
should know before they press play on
tonight's episode what should they be
mentally prepared for because I want to
say have tissues tissues that's a good
one I would say yeah I want to copy that
have tissues I mean I was getting
emotional filming one at one of the
scenes personally yeah yeah I mean it's
a it's an incredible episode I I think
there's you know everything that you've
seen leading up to it is starting to
culminate right now and so yeah you have
to come ready and yes yeah well we've
got time for just a few more fan
questions so we'll do some rapid fire
ones right now girls got everything on
YouTube says when will there be more
Shoni we are here for it love you
Vanessa and I'm hope I love you too
hopefully soon and I'm just so pumped
that you guys are loving our
relationship and I think you know just
gonna we're just gonna get closer as a
couple cuz you know we are
girlfriend and girlfriend now so yeah
hopefully you guys will see more of us
soon Sophie on youtube or it's Sophie on
YouTube says will there be a marriage in
Riverdale that's a good question cuz
who's really I everyone's kind of young
still and and we need to do malice to
the adulterer
married yes whether their relationships
are falling apart or not they're still
with someone yeah that's a good question
no there might be it may be a union of
sorts there could be a union just leave
you at anna p on facebook says are we
gonna find out who the black hood is and
do you guys know yes and yes yeah
obviously i know we know who it is you
you find out things yes so well i think
it's yeah it's a bit up in the air but
i'll go ahead and say that you fans out
there should be sure to check each
eonline after you watch tonight's
episode because i may or may not have an
exclusive interview with the black hood
going up live so with all of your
lingering questions that will be
answered got Yoshi to do and I'm that
known Vanessa in ski thank you so much
for stopping by sweet Auto Secrets live
I really appreciate it I'm so excited
for season 3 and we will be talking
about some of the other good stuff so
we're gonna go offline I'm gonna keep
talking with these guys
[Music]
you